what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I'm going to be
reacting to the great Jordan Peterson I
have not reacted to him in a minute so
it's interesting watching all of this
red pill content and then going back to
Jordan Peterson's I think that Jordan
Peterson is like a little bit more
conservative and leaning uh he's a
little bit red pill but not as much as
you know some of the stuff I've done
like deep dives into so um it'll be
interesting to go back and watch his
older content where he talks about what
women don't understand about men men use
the image of female Perfection to
motivate themselves
and that's exactly right that's
precisely what they do you see that in
the Tom Sawyer's story so Tom Sawyer is
about 12 years old and he's still
hanging around with his friends like
Huck Finn and this girl moves across the
street Becky and she comes out and he's
struck by her for the first time in his
life something's changed and the first
thing he does is hop up on a picket
fence and show off and balance in front
of her and he's saying well look at me
look at me I'm he's like the male Bower
bird building something beautiful so the
female will approve of it and it's it's
motivation
you know and that's something that I
think modern women don't really
understand about men they don't
understand that
at least to the degree that males are
uncorrupted and not better because of
being rejected they're doing everything
they can to kneel before the Eternal
image of the feminine
and try to make themselves Worthy
that's the chivalry story right that's
what you should encourage in your
partner so and so out of chaos emerges
this first form it's the feminine form
it's partly the form that represents
novelty as such
so and and on one hand it's promise on
the other hand it's threat that you
wouldn't believe and I don't know
because I don't know I don't understand
the situation with women as well as I
understand the situation with men
obviously being a man cannot understand
this chart it says chaos is over there
so is that like the devil okay chaos I'm
sorry guys I'm slow so then on the other
side is a lady whose novelty what does
that say okay promise threat anxiety
hope okay but I
I don't know if women have any idea
how paralyzing they are to especially
young men
a large very large number of my clinical
clients but also young men I've talked
to in general are absolutely terrified
of women because they're terrified of
being rejected and the terror exists in
precise proportion to the retraction to
the woman which is a horrible
paradoxical situation to be in it's
often why men make such fools of
themselves in front of women that
they're attracted to it's because first
of all they don't see the woman that
they're attracted to because what the
hell do they know about her they don't
see her as an individual they see her as
the manifestation of a judgmental ideal
and then it's only in establishing the
relationship with the actual woman that
they can start differentiating between
the judgmental ideal and and the actual
individual woman and that also requires
a sacrifice and the sacrifice is
you never can have an ideal woman
so to have a relationship with any woman
you have to sacrifice the relationship
with the ideal woman and you have to see
the individual woman
and separate her from the ideal and
that's the same thing that happens to
the hero in Sleeping Beauty right am I
not even gonna lie he lost me oh so he's
saying you have to accept how women are
oh so let's kind of like take the red
pill in a way yeah because you have to
you have to accept women for how they
are not what you want them to be the
evil queen who actually turns into the
dragon of chaos and it's not until he
can he can defeat her that he can
establish a relationship with the actual
princess and that's exactly the case I
had a one of my clients who ran this
men's group which was quite interesting
one of the things they had the initiates
do which was very intelligent was to go
out and ask 50 women in one day for
their phone numbers
do which was very intelligent was to go
out and ask 50 women in one day for
their phone numbers
why politely properly you know it wasn't
it wasn't it was a game but it wasn't a
stupid game and the idea was get over
your fear of rejection and how do you do
that but I think that's good advice
actually because there aren't many men
that approach people in broad daylight
in my opinion maybe it's just me I don't
know but but I feel like guys that
actually approach you in person you're a
lot more likely to like follow up with
in my opinion countering it continually
and continually and continually so that
you're no longer Paralyzed by this the
person that you can completely map and
who only does positive things for you
it's like a you don't know that person B
they're not communicating with you nor
are you with them maybe they're just
subordinating themselves to you or you
to them and you're not growing you want
someone who can it's a real relationship
is a wrestling match it's a grappling
it's a grappling phenomena that you both
emerge transformed from and that's what
people want they don't want to push over
not not unless there's something wrong
with them and a narcissistic person who
never wants to be challenged will want a
partner who does nothing but deliver
exactly what they're told to deliver but
they will mistreat them beyond belief
what does the optimal relationship look
like in terms of positive and negative I
don't think men want someone they have
to contend with I think women do so it's
I wonder why he says that because in my
experience I don't think that men
generally want a woman that they have to
contend with and argue with all the time
like what does he mean by contend with I
guess is the question you might say well
Utopia nothing but positive interactions
it's like no
imagine you get people to code
the interactions they have with their
partner during the day you know you
sample it you say was that interaction
positive or negative and then what
you're trying to do is predict the
longevity of the relationship okay so
here's the data
if it falls under oh I've heard this I
have positive interactions to one
negative interaction the relationship
doesn't continue fair enough too much
negative that's easy to understand if it
exceeds 11 positive to one negative the
relationship doesn't last why
they're passive aggressive
no challenge
right what do you want from your partner
Bliss no no no you don't the women will
leave actually that's my conclusion is
that there's too many positive
interactions the girl will leave because
what I would be curious is if they took
those like who broke up with who and my
guess is it was the woman I'm sorry
Jordan the representation of Diana you
could think of Diana there's an opposite
uh Durga
in Hinduism and she comes forth if you
make the proper sacrifices to Kelly but
I wanted to show you alternative
representations from different cultures
of these archetypal forms this is Diana
positive feminine what multi-breasted
right she's the thing that nourishes the
world and so that was yeah a girl has a
lot of boobs
a lot of boo you see that I see a lot I
mean on one hand your mother who
obviously protects you from the terrible
aspects of fire and danger but also my
nature conceptualized as the positive
feminine in general
the source of all fertility and all food
and all beings and all good things
something that you want to have on your
side that's for sure and you might say
if you acted heroically properly and you
played the metagame and not the game and
you made the proper sacrifices then
you'd never encounter Kelly you'd only
encounter her benevolent counterpart and
so then you might say well does she even
exist then that's something that's very
interesting is because the degree to
which the terrible part of the world
manifests itself in your life is
proportionate to how insufficient you
are and we don't know the full extent of
that if you got your act together
basically if you suck then you're the
people that you around you are going to
suck too
deeply
maybe all the suffering would disappear
from your life or at least maybe all the
unbearable suffering and maybe all the
suffering or the unbearable suffering
from the lives of people around you too
and you already know that because there
are people that you'll go to in a crisis
that you can rely on and you know
they'll help you and you wonder what the
world would be like if you were like
that and everyone else was like that too
we'd have a lot fewer crises and the
ones that we do have would be a lot more
manageable
and so when people say well why is the
world so Rife with suffering one answer
to that is because we're not yet what we
could be and at least that's an answer
that we have some control over right
you're not going to talk God out of
making the world suffer that's for sure
and you're not going to negotiate
directly with mother nature but you
might be able to put yourself together a
little bit and see if that works at
least it's under your control and God
only knows what the upper limit of that
might be you can tell when someone has
like a victim mindset and it's the most
draining thing to be around it is so
draining blah blah blah the world is
against me just big whiners big babies
and so it's really refreshing when
you're around people that just they
believe they're in control of everything
and the things that they're not in
control of Carolyn Health you know guys
let me know if there's any old Jordan
Peterson videos I should react to let me
know what I should react to next message
my Instagram just probably things one if
you have special requests for me to
react to you like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time